Film Courage: What makes a terrible pitch?
Kelly Edwards, Staff Writer, Author, Producer:
Probably not enough preparation, not knowing
your character or your world. There are staples
to every pitch everybody needs to know why you're
the one to write the pitch the show. You need to
know your character really well. You need to know
what and how they operate within the world. what
the conflict is, what's the ensemble around them
and if you can't articulate that it can be a mess
but I don't think anybody ever walks
into a pitch thinking it's going to be
a terrible pitch. They don't want to make
a terrible pitch, that happens by accident
but when a show and you're passionate about
a show showing that passion goes a long way
that can really remedy a lot of ills even if you
aren't great at articulating them in the way that
you think is the smoothest way to do it. I think
sometimes just your enthusiasm for the material
and knowing that material and knowing what
you want to say can be make all the difference
I know it's a it's it terrifies people
it's a terrifying thing to go in there and
want to tell a story really well and not wanting
to screw up and because you don't want to screw up
you end up screwing up but you have to remember
that people have heard a lot of these things
they've heard a thousand of these pitches and
you're not bringing anything new it's very rare
that you're bringing in something that's so wholly
different but what you are bringing is yourself
and that coupled with the idea is
why people want you to write it
and remember they're not they're not creating
a show for you to sit and tell the story on
television right that's not the you pitching
is not the show the show is what how you're
going to execute it on the page so I think
if you can release some of that anxiety
and just go in and tell us and talk about why you
love something and why you think it's a great idea
then the details don't matter especially if you
if you if you're the person who comes in with a
note card or you come in with your your page and
your page is shaking acknowledge it and just go
I'm awful at this there are plenty of people who
are terrible pitchers who end up selling things
so if you could just hang a lantern on
it and just go look I'm gonna botch this
terribly but guess what I love this so much
and I think you should love it so much then
I think you could I could think you
could sweep by it sounds like then
terrible pitch isn't nervousness it's lack of
enthusiasm well you could be nervous but again
if you're nervous there are so many other ways
to mitigate that so bring a partner or bring
your agent or bring somebody who's gonna fill in
the blanks think who's gonna be your wingman so
there are ways to do that again you can write it
down you can you can have them you can send them
the deck in advance these days it's it's all
on a zoom zoom has been the best thing in the
world for people who are terrible pitchers because
you can read your document no one's going to know
so there are ways that you can get around
it I think barring a flop sweat I think
I think anybody can can muscle through and again
it's what you are on the page so if you they love
you on the page and they've already said that
they've loved you because you're in that room
whether it's a zoom room where it's in
person so you've already got over the
hurdle the biggest hurdle and then you just
have to convince them that you have enough
insight into the character and the world
really well and there's something to say
that there's a relevancy to what you're saying
then you've got a lot of the big pieces but
when someone lacks enthusiasm then it doesn't
matter if they're smooth as is butter with their
delivery but it's there's just something it's not
convincing well here's the thing who would want
to work with somebody who's not enthusiastic
about a job because you are then spending as
we said 12 hours a day on set for 22 Episodes or
eight episodes or however many it's a lot of time
it's the bulk of your year right you're CR coming
up with a pitch and then getting in the room to
pitch takes a long time to do it so if you're
not interested in it why do it what's the point
so you have to be enthusiastic
otherwise do something else
if a pitch or screenplay is rejected how does that
writer build a relationship with the executives
oh okay when you say rejected though what are you
talking about are you talking about somebody that
has already sold something and is rejected or
before you even get to the place where you're
meeting for General you're having
a general and it's sorry to pass
okay but if it's again if you're sitting in the
room with an executive you've already won they
are already on your on on your team right so it's
up to you to then give them something that they
that they will like or maybe it's just not for
them and maybe it's just the wrong timing so
there are there have always been times when
we're looking for a and you're bringing us
B so we really need a family comedy for this
slot but you're bringing us an action comedy
and we don't have space for it nor can we afford
it whatever it is it might not be the right time
so your past might have nothing to do with you as
a human being or your writing your skill or your
or whether I like you it might be a factor of many
other things that you have no idea the problem is
is that we always take it personally we think it's
us you've said no and I take it personally right
so you have to get past that because again as we
said before executives are running a mile a minute
they are managing a lot of things there's a lot
of balls in the air and that one thing might
not be right so keep moving let's keep moving
because I've already invited you into my space
I've already said I like your writing you you now
it's on you to say okay that didn't work let me
here's what I would do if I was in that position
you've just passed to me you go I'm sorry it's
not working I go what what are you looking
for now there's a whole new conversation or
oh yeah yeah I totally understand that thank
you so much for reading it that's so great
let me float another thing by you something
I'm working on what do you think about this
and then you've hooked somebody with another I
you don't even have to have the idea you could
say what I'm thinking about doing something about
mother-daughter relationships or something about
dystopian worlds and how somebody navigates that
then again you've then opened up another line of
conversation where then that executive can say oh
and you get something more come back and Pitch it
to me that's a conversation now how do you land
the plane in that meeting the end of the meeting
hopefully you say what my agent put us in touch
I would really love to have a direct line to you
is that okay can I can I share my card with
you or can I give my information directly to
your assistant or can I have your number or is it
okay if I reach out in a couple weeks there are
ways to have a conversation and particularly if
you've connected over something so let's just say
you guys both have kids who are in AYSO hey
what I wonder are you going to be at the turkey
tournament I would love to see you let's grab
coffee there whatever it is there are threads
everywhere that you can pull that's why being
in a room a real room with somebody gives you
all of the other information about that person
what are the posters they have on the wall what
shows did they do what's the coffee table book
that they have everybody's got a coffee day book
what's the pictures that are on there on their
desk there's something that you can then key
into and ask that person about themselves in that
way and then connect it back so that you start
a relationship just as though you would do with
anybody so there's there are ways to continue the
conversation then too and even if you don't hear
back from them it doesn't mean that they haven't
received the information there's many times that
I would get an email and I was running so fast
that I didn't think to respond but I still
saw the email I still saw that person's name
that person still was on my mind so
don't think that a no answer is no answer
so that's the error is thinking that it's
rejection when really they've invited you
there they've given you whatever amount of time
so that's actually not a rejection yeah and then
you're it's sort of the door is slightly open and
then it's up to you to make the next move and to
show that you've made some progress so for and you
and we're we're so good as human beings of filling
in the blanks we're like ah they hated me and
then you go through down a rabbit hole where you
just you just wonder all the things that you did
wrong and I must have crossed my legs in the wrong
place and I know when I took the Sip I choked
on my water and oh they just hate me and you go
down this place that has absolutely no bearing on
reality because again they are the star of their
own movie and they're thinking about something
else they just said oh my God I had a really
great meeting and I wonder what I'm gonna get
back and then it's up to you you have to deliver
and remember too again we are the a town of show
me something like show me you're moving forward
if you're sitting in stasis if you're locked in
a block of ice and you are not moving forward
I don't really have time for you I want the
person who's actually out there doing something
so as soon as we show a little as a as a writer
as soon as you show a little moment on your own
we will then re-engage so you get into a program
oh I'm re-engaging with you or you I don't know
are you with a competition or someone else has
brought your name up and then I'm re-engaging
so and you don't know what's happening under the
surface so there's a whole network of things that
happen constantly that we are never privy to
because no one's saying I did this for you
but there are also many times where someone
would come in to me meet with me and have a
great meeting I didn't have anything for them at
the time but it didn't mean that I didn't push
that material to the current department or push
that material to a friend of mine at a different
network or mention that name somewhere or give
a recommendation to that for that writer to a
program so there's a whole other network of things
that are churning below the service surf surface
that are happening that are really working in your
favor and eventually all those things are going to
line up somewhere eventually there's going to
be a critical mass and those people are going
to hear your name a couple of times they're going
to go oh my god I've heard that person's so great
and then so when you your little bubble
Pops to the top that's when your little
Horton Hears a Who Yap comes out right and all
of a sudden we are here we're here we're here.